who in the nba have you played a game of
2k with and they've beaten you
what
[Music]
zion what is up so much to discuss today
but how are you feeling i'm feeling
great how about your stuff
i'm feeling good you know i'm always
happy when i get to play some games so
that is what we are gonna do right now
gonna play a game called heads up it's
my favorite um a word is going to pop up
on the screen and you are going to get
me to guess it or i'm going to get you
to guess it you're going to go first
so
close your eyes
because you can't see the word on the
screen all right and the category for
this one is basketball okay
ready
okay this is the team in texas that's
not san antonio nba team
uh houston
houston what yeah
okay this is jaylen brown jason tatum's
team
um the boston celtics yep
okay so this is when you the person
who's breaking down exactly what's
happening on the court they're giving
you a
commentator
yeah but what is that called
we'll skip that one let's get that one
okay uh this was the olympic squad that
was great michael jordan was on it
leightoner was on it the dream team yep
when you have to go in the huddle during
the game your coach calls a
time out yep
uh this is uh right before the elite
eight
316. yay
you got it the bubbler listen i have
played this game with a lot of athletes
and they have not done as well as you
that was that was impressive okay you
don't have to hike me up
so speaking of games you of course are
part of the new uh 2k22 have you gotten
a chance to play it yet and if so what
what were your first impressions
i haven't played nba 2k 22 yet but
uh
a part of the game i'm looking forward
to playing is uh
the mountain dew three-point shootout um
i think i'm gonna put my player in that
a lot you know
just so you can win a few of those
just because
but i say that's my favorite part i'm
looking forward to
so right now you have a rating of 89.
do you agree or disagree with that
number what's your take all right i have
two takes on it my first take
they blessed me with the cover last year
i am forever grateful second take
when i stopped playing i was a knight
nothing happened since then
what what what did i do for it to go
drop down already
but hey that's just me
it is what it is
no listen state your case why should
your number be higher i want to hear it
should my number be higher because on me
no guy is ever satisfied with what their
number is whenever the ratings come out
it's what everybody's tweeting about and
instagramming about is that they didn't
get this number right so tell me that
process of going to find your rating and
the thing that first comes into your
mind when you see it well when i first
hear about my rating it's usually from
twitter
and
i thought it was a typo at first i was
like oh type of
yeah
you know i took a double double take
that's oh 89
okay
whatever
is what it is so what do you want your
number to be by the end of the season
what's what's the goal here for the
rating
uh 94.95
okay
we made a special deck that is all
catered to you so now i'm gonna close my
eyes and you get me to guess these words
okay
all right
okay all right eyes are closed
uh
can we skip that one
i was on the cover of this video game
last year
nba 2k okay
uh
i play he he coached me in college
oh uh uh chaszewski
okay
uh the team i played for in the nba
uh new orleans pelicans okay
uh
yeah
you have to heads up it's a little
harder than you think when it's
described but it's always a fun game
that was fun it was fun
i'm gonna name some players you tell me
what you think their rating is okay
okay all right
kd knowing 2k and knowing that they're
not gonna give him a 99 or 98
i'll say 96.
okay
what do you think lebron's number is
96. uh giannis
uh 96.
steph
96. so it seems like you got to know
where i'm going with that so although
those are the four guys that are all 96
but the talk online was kd saying he
felt he should be in 99. lebron also
chimed in said that he feels that kevin
should be a 99 you said you agree it
should be 99 but you know he's 96 what
makes kd a 99 player
i think we all witnessed it um
last year in the playoffs uh
he just put on a basketball clinic and i
feel like anybody who respects the game
of basketball
you just know how to appreciate
greatness and what we saw
so even though all of those guys are
96s and they all agree kd 99 including
you you have kd here
if you had to rank those other guys what
would you rank them
uh off off respect and uh what he's done
for the game
i give i'll give lebron 99 i mean he's
what he's done for the game uh
nobody else is done so i get respect
when he's due
giannis i'll give him a 97.98 you know
championship wanted in milwaukee i got a
lot of respect for that
curry same thing 97 98 uh
nobody does what he does
uh what was the first 2k version that
you played i think the first 2k i played
might have been
like 2k6 i think either shaq or d wade
was on the cover when you play 2k do you
play with the pelicans do you use
another team what's your go-to i mix it
up i'll play with the pelicans and then
i'll play with uh some of my other
friends in the league
just to try to learn their game see what
2k thinks about them like strategic
stuff like that so would you consider
yourself a gamer
or at least a 2k gamer i consider myself
a 2k gamer
how good would you say you are
okay
on a normal scale
yeah but a normal scale number ten
if you're talking about real life gaming
like professionals
i'm a four
like
just be honest
who in the nba have you played a game of
2k with and they've beaten you
so no one in the nba has ever beaten you
in nba 2k i haven't played a lot of
people but no no one owns this vehicle
well zion thank you for your time i'm
excited to see what the game looks like
and i will also be keeping track if you
actually hit that 95 this season
thank you for having me and
yeah hopefully i'll get there hopefully
the 2k well
rates me correctly hopefully i'll get
there
bye
[Music]